TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Hello, and welcome
to "The Developer Show."
This is your TLDR.
Project Tango is
hosting workshops
to help bring indoor
location apps to life.
You may remember our visit
to one of these workshops
a couple episodes ago.
It was really cool.
Follow the link to read more
and submit your own idea.
To help your business
grow, we are significantly
increasing the size limits of
all Google Compute Engine block
storage products, including up
to three terabytes of local SSD
and 64 terabytes of persistent
disk per virtual machine.
Check out the post
for more details.
If you enjoy debating the merits
of the spark and data flow
programming models, you
get excited at the idea
of processing terabytes in
seconds with zero setup,
or simply want to learn how
to use the infrastructure
that powers Google for
your data processing work,
this new blog on
big data is for you.
Dart 1.14 is now
available and contains
a number of additions
and improvements
across our core
libraries and tools,
including progress
towards eliminating
symbolic links and a new way
to access package assets easily
and reliably.
The newest Chrome Beta release
includes CSS custom properties,
background sync with
service workers,
and new ECMAScript
2015 features.
Check out the blog
post and the Beta.
Over the last
couple weeks, we've
published a bunch
of new articles
on our Web Updates page.
Check out all the
great new content,
including information
on ECMAScript proxies,
controlling font
performance, and more.
Invalid activity consists
of any clicks or impressions
that may artificially
inflate an advertiser's costs
or a publisher's earnings.
Learn how you can avoid invalid
activity with these quick tips.
Intelligence is not the product
of any singular mechanism
but comes from the
managed interaction
of a diverse variety
of resourceful agents.
This and other big ideas came
from the work of Marvin Minsky,
a pioneer in
artificial intelligence
and winner of Turing
Award in 1969.
He recently died
at the age of 88.
For more on Minsky's work,
check out this great article
by the "The New York Times."
Women Techmakers is
Google's global program
for women in tech and is hosting
14 summits at Google offices,
and 100 meet-ups are expected
with Google Developer groups
globally to celebrate
International Women's
Day in March and April.
Follow the link and
apply to attend.
They're going to be awesome.
That's your TLDR for this week.
Now, you may notice
that I'm in front
of a highly refined and
sophisticated podcast studio.
We've taken down the
Android UI toolkit fan art,
but you can still probably guess
this is where Chet Haas and Tor
Norbye record their podcast
"Android Developers Backstage."
I talked shop with Chet
and Tor earlier today,
and this is how it went.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Hello, and welcome to
"Android Developers Backstage,"
the podcast.
I'm Chet Haase from--
-I'm Tor Norbye from the
Android [INAUDIBLE] team.
-We're kind of backstage at
"Android Developers Backstage,"
which is pretty neat.
This is your clubhouse.
-Actually, this is the
backstage and the front stage.
We're engineers.
We get one stage.
-So let's talk about "Android
Developers Backstage."
What is it?
How'd you come up with the idea?
It's been around for two years.
-Yeah.
-Are you filling a need
here, or is this your hobby?
-Are we-- I don't want to
think about that too deeply.
Has my life been
worthwhile, or is it just
a pile of meaninglessness?
I'm just going to go home
make a warm bath with--
-It's actually fun
for us because it's
a way for us to talk to
people that we work with,
but we don't really
know what they do.
And this is the perfect excuse
to ask all the dumb questions
that we wouldn't probably
otherwise admit to not knowing.
-Actually. yeah, the
funnest part of the show
is that we're actually
learning about stuff.
I think there the reason
it works, at least I'm
going to pretend
that it actually
works for people, because
the whole point of the show
is to teach people or
educate people or help people
understand deeper parts of
the platform, the bigger
picture of how
Android works, how
technology works in general,
APIs, deeper stuff, whatever.
And it's not like we're
pretending, giving
prompting questions so
that those people can
talk to the audience.
No, they're talking to us.
We don't know either.
So we talk to people
who are domain experts
in the thing that they do.
And then they tell us about
it, and along the way,
they happen to be speaking
into a microphone.
We happen to be recording it.
And hopefully, other
people are benefiting
from the conversation as well.
-Who's the most surprising
guest that came on?
And it's like, I had no idea
that was true about Android.
-For me, it was one
of the early episodes.
It was on security.
And I wasn't expecting
to be as fun as it was.
But that episode with
Adrian Ludwig on security,
didn't he have some background?
He'd been working for like the--
-NSA or CIA?
- --yeah, CIA or something.
And he was just
totally-- he would
talk about things I didn't
think he would talk about,
like what we thought of
virus checkers on Android
and things like.
So I remember that episode.
I was really surprised by how it
was just surprisingly exciting.
-So a couple things, I think
the episode in particular
that I though that we could
have just gone on for days,
and we actually did break
it into two was art.
So we had Anwar on to talk
about garbage collectors,
which being a graphics person,
I wouldn't think that I would
find inherently
interesting, because there
are no pixels involved.
But it's fascinating actually,
the way the runtime works,
the way garbage
collection works,
the way you can
optimize these things,
the way things have
gotten better over time.
So we just sort of
went on and on and on,
and it was an hour
and a half later.
-So what you think is the
coolest thing happening
in the development
community right now,
not the stuff that we're making
available via the platform,
but the coolest
thing that developers
are doing with Android?
-Well, so if you're only
just doing the platform,
then I would say
Android Studio, clearly.
Because that's not the
platform, but it's something
that is super exciting.
-Yeah, and the
speed improvements
are incredible with instant run.
-I don't know, I mean, the
great thing about the platform,
it's such a huge ecosystem
with developers is people
do all kinds of crazy stuff.
-I think that's the
thing with Android that's
really cool is that every week
or so there's something just
really surprising that
somebody's doing with Android
that's really, really cool.
-I think actually one of
the guests that we had
on that was surprising
to us, or we
knew about it going
into the studio,
but the nearby stuff
I was really cool
was like using audio as like
a transmission protocol.
-The ultrasonic audio.
-Yeah, that was
such a neat hack.
-Well, what I think is
really neat about that
is blending that with Bluetooth,
low energy, and other things
sort of in the background.
And so you get that stuff,
no matter how it happens.
I think that's
what's really cool.
So I think we're
nearly out of time.
Is there anything else you want
to tell people about "Android
Developers Backstage"
that you don't
get to talk about on the show?
-Listen?
-Yeah, that's what I
like about podcasts,
that I can listen to podcasts
while I'm driving or doing
dishes or whatever.
So it's a good way to get
more technical knowledge
while it's downtime.
-I think that's all
the time that we have.
Chet, Tor, thank you very
much for taking the time
to chat with me about
stuff and things.
And for all of you out there,
if you haven't already,
please subscribe to the
"Android Developers Backstage"
podcast for all the inside
scoop on everything Android.
-It's on your favorite
podcast client.
It's also-- we
have a blog, where
we publish show notes and
really exciting pictures.
So check it out wherever
you can find it.
-Cool, you'll find all the
links in the description below.
Things again, guys.
-Thanks.
[END PLAYBACK]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And if you
have any questions for anybody
here at the Googleplex, remember
to use the hashtag askDevShow.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]